et voilà c'était entre deux mondes un
documentaire de Sonia et Didi qui nous
fait l'honneur de participer à Z la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup et puis à vos côtés nous
avons le plaisir d'accueillir abdela
Issou bonjour ancien sous préfet de
l'Oise vous êtes passés par le cabinet
du ministre de l'Intérieur à l'époque
c'était Dominique de Villepin vous étiez
chargé de l'égalité des chances tiens ça
tombe plutôt bien et puis vous avez un
parcours que d'aucun qualifierait
d'atypique alors vous nous direz puis
vous direz surtout aux élèves ainsi vous
avez le sentiment d'être passé vous
aussi d'un monde à l'autre merci
infiniment à vous de d'avoir accepté
notre invitation enfin surtout
l'invitation de la classe troisième e du
collège Albert Camus bonjour les élèves
bonjour Merci d'avoir travaillé sur ce
film avec votre professeur de français
et votre professeur d'histoire-géo vous
avez regardé ce documentaire vous l'avez
travaillé je sais que vous avez plein de
questions à poser à nos deux invités
mais juste avant de démarrer j'aimerais
tout simplement bien connaître votre
sentiment votre ressenti sur ce film
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé
à la place de tout quand ils étaient
quand ils étaient chez eux quand ils
étaient en cours leurs pensées et tout
c'est de donner moi ce qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est au début du documentaire
quand ils font la sélection des
candidats pour le programme à quel point
c'est impartial certains élèves peuvent
être refusés pour de des notes qui sont
très proches des attentes et pourtant
ils sont refusés
on voyait que leurs parents étaient
fiers d'eux et qui voulait vraiment
qu'ils y arrivent jusqu'à au jusqu'au
lycée en fait on faisait on parlait trop
des trajets et aussi quand il parlait
des devoirs mais sinon après on dirait
une tu es en pleine immersion dans le
avec eux les suivait partout quand ils
allaient parler entre eux que j'étais en
cours quand ils prenait le bus quand il
se retrouvait c'est bien aussi moi le
truc qui m'a marqué c'est que
la fille là où il s'aime non je pense
les personnes et bah elle elle voulait
plus faire ça mais elle continue quand
même pour ses parents parce que vous
voulez les rendre fier et ben vous allez
pouvoir poser toutes vos questions mais
si je crois que tu voulais poser une
question à Sonia Didi pourquoi avez-vous
choisi ce titre alors entre deux mondes
on l'a choisi parce que je le film était
justement l'opportunité de parler de
cette différence entre le monde des
milieux élitistes tels que le lycée
Henri IV et la banlieue donc l'idée
c'était de montrer justement les codes
qui peut y avoir entre ces deux mondes
donc et de raconter justement tout
bêtement le fait qu'il y a donc deux
mondes qui séparent la banlieue et les
lycées élitistes et surtout les pas les
quartiers favoriser tels que le Quartier
Latin à Paris vous saviez que le lycée
il existait non toi tu savais ridoine ok
d'autres ne savaient pas est-ce que ça
vous a donné envie de le faire est-ce
que ça vous a donné envie de vous
inscrire à Henri 4 non personne
pas trop compris c'est trop compliqué et
c'est un peu trop strict envers les
profs et je trouve que que
les inscriptions sont un peu trop
strictes et que ça donne encore plus de
pression déjà il y a la distance pour
certains qui qui les sépare et aussi que
c'est comme on l'a tous dit c'est
strictes c'est compliqué et il y a que
les excellents qui réussissent là-bas je
voulais vous poser cette question
qu'est-ce que vous avez compris de ce
documentaire de ce film s'il y avait un
message quel serait-il Yassine dans un
dans un parcours scolaire il y a des il
y a des échecs comme des réussites et
après une réussite on est content mais
après chaque échec il faut avoir le
mental solide et pouvoir se relever
après chaque échec
et après c'est comme ça qu'on avance
travail pour réussir c'est un travail
pas bah c'est l'échec comme on l'a vu la
fille qu'avec un devoir comparé aux
autres qui est qu'elle avait rendu 4
elle est pas fourni à cette travail du
coup c'est ça elle rend pas tous ses
devoirs et la prof elle lui dit à la fin
elle est pas admise
c'est ce qu'on peut voir et peu importe
si les élèves ont été sélectionnés ou
non ils ont réussi dans leurs études
après et puis ils ont ils ont continué à
avancer sans soucier de l'échec qu'ils
avaient essuyé
j'ai vu d'autres mains levée
c'est ce que tu as compris toi de
documentaire et vous c'était quoi le but
de vous voulez faire parce que le
message déjà je voulais montrer à quel
point dans ces familles là les parents
les poussent énormément c'était ça aussi
que je voulais montrer parce que je
trouve qu'on le voit pas assez souvent
moi je sais que ma grand-mère qui était
avec qui je vivais à l'époque pendant
mon adolescence qui était analphabète
elle savait ni lire ni écrire et le
matin elle me disant quand je voulais
pas me réveiller j'avais la j'étais
j'avais un peu la flemme j'étais une ado
un peu comme tout le monde et elle me
disait en kabyle accueil accueil ça
faisait réveille-toi réveille-toi va à
l'école et elle c'était vraiment la
priorité pour elle c'était aller à
l'école je rentrais elle était souvent
elle devant la télé elle était née moi
je voulais regarder avec elle non elle
était née la tête pour que je fasse mes
devoirs ma mère c'est pareil bon ma mère
elle est née en France elle parle très
bien français elle a fait des études etc
mais je voulais aussi montrer que dans
ces familles là contrairement à ce que
certaines personnes peuvent penser bah
oui les parents ils ont peut-être tous
les outils mais en tout cas ils ont
tellement d'amour et d'envies pour pour
leurs enfants qui donnent tout Romaissa
est-ce que vous connaissez les cordées
de la réussite
président Denis soumise qui était
ministre de la Ville qui l'a mis en
place c'est un dispositif intéressant
avec une image de montagne puisque la
cordée on s'enchaîne et puis on grimpe
quelque chose c'est bien c'est bien mais
ça ne peut pas épuiser tout le reste
parce que
la vie n'est pas faite que de Henri IV
ou de zone d'éducation prioritaire la
vraie vie c'est la différence c'est donc
je connais bien les cordées parce
qu'elles permettent de corriger des
écarts du système
pour créer de l'égalité des chances mais
je préférerais que l'ensemble du système
se régule par lui-même ce qui est
malheureusement n'est pas le cas
comment vous avez fait pour passer Léna
alors que vous êtes né dans un milieu
défavoris les enfants d'ouvriers ont pas
autant accès que les autres à
Polytechnique Alena à Henri IV agent
soin de saillie quelqu'un d'autre
grandissait parisien et ça pour appeler
un chien achat c'est pas normal parce
que dans liberté égalité fraternité
l'égalité c'est pas un principe abstrait
et de ce point de vue là
notre pays malheureusement garantit pas
ça et donc pour répondre maintenant
directement à ta question si j'ai bossé
comme un malade j'ai jamais autant
travaillé de ma vie j'ai étudié étudié
étudié ça n'est pas facile mais
le fait que les cordée de la réussite le
fait qui est certaine prépa le fait
qu'il y a ce corps enseignant formidable
ça veut dire qu'il faut y croire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout est codifié
[Musique]
comment avez-vous choisi les élèves je
suis allé voir les chefs d'établissement
qui eux m'ont donné des les listings en
fait les listes des élèves qui
candidataient et donc là en fait je suis
parti chez les familles je suis allé
rencontrer les familles et donc voilà
j'ai fait du porte à porte je suis allé
les voir et c'est facilement non ça a
été au début un peu difficile parce que
c'est beaucoup de familles qui sont très
pudiques qui ont pas forcément envie de
se mettre en avant qui ont pas forcément
être passé à la télévision qui ont pas
forcément envie qu'on film chez elle et
puis après il fallait aussi une amitié
qui se crée entre les jeunes et moi et
quand j'ai rencontré les jeunes que vous
avez vu dans le film donc on y ça Marwa
wissal Baidi ça a été vraiment aussi un
coup de coeur humain parce que je me
suis vachement projetée aussi dans ce
que moi j'ai vécu plus jeune et tout
elles ont toutes et tous qu'il y a aussi
baïti ils ont tous une particularité ils
ont tous une personnalité différente
mais ce qu'il est réuni c'est qu'ils ont
une envie une volonté parce qu'il
faudrait être courageux pour aller faire
justement d'où l'intérêt des transports
1h30 de transport tous les jours en plus
de leur cours
et en plus voilà il leur famille aussi
qui les soutenaient donc voilà c'est
comme ça que j'ai les cheveux je les ai
choisis
le domicile des élèves et que ce que
cela raconte pour vous très très bonne
question
tout simplement aussi pour montrer leur
univers social c'est-à-dire d'où ils
viennent quel héritage social ils ont
reçu
en termes de langage en termes c'est
pour ça que c'était important pour moi
de les filmer autour d'une table parce
que c'est souvent autour d'une table
qu'on discute dans une vie de famille et
fier parce qu'elle va Henri IV
parce qu'elle est bonne à l'école elle
est bonne à l'école
c'est sûr tu vois que la génération qui
réalise les rêves
à travers cela l'idée c'était de
comprendre quelles sont les différences
entre l'héritage social qu'ils ont reçu
et ce qu'ils apprennent justement dans
ces cours Henri IV leur relation
justement avec ses professeurs qui
viennent d'un univers qui est quand même
différent si on vous l'avait proposé
vous auriez participé à ce documentaire
à l'époque où vous étiez
étudiant au collège au lycée
je crois pas pourquoi parce que
d'abord
moi je suis d'origine kabyle dans la
culture kabyle il y a énormément de
pudeur et donc
il y a une difficulté à une difficulté
c'est une culture c'est une fin qu'on se
raconte pas on avance donc je ne pense
pas non même si
en ayant un peu vieilli je me rends
compte qu'il est important de parler de
témoigner d'échanger
que les meilleurs
le but c'est d'ailleurs les meilleurs
parce que le mot meilleur moi j'aime pas
trop ce mot mais
c'est quoi pour vous être le meilleur
être meilleur c'est dur d'avoir des
bonnes notes partout
être excellent partout voilà est-ce que
le meilleur c'est forcément avoir des
bonnes notes ah non c'est quoi alors
être le meilleur oui tout le monde
comment
avoir toujours l'ascendant sur quelqu'un
c'est ça pour toi être le meilleur bah
c'est être au-dessus des autres chacun
il peut être fort dans un domaine
que lui au sport ça dépend
être le meilleur c'est être comme si on
était parfait alors que personne n'est
parfait
à quelque chose qui va vraiment pas dans
le système éducatif français si on
émette objective
il y en a d'autres mais celle là c'est
justement le fait de penser qu'il y a
des meilleurs
il y en a qui réussissent un peu plus la
compétition c'est une compétition mais
un pays pour se construire il peut pas
se construire qu'avec les 5% ou les deux
pour cent qui vont faire les nappes
Polytechnique Enrica toujours son
saillie et le but c'est que si on
sacrase trop
des gens sont de saillie ce quelqu'un on
oublie l'immense majorité des autres et
du coup derrière les meilleurs on dit
pas les autres il y a l'idée de les plus
mauvais et ça on touche quelques tu vois
ce que j'essaye de dire et donc une
équipe de football il y a pas que des
Killian Mbappé dedans une équipe elle
gagne avec des gens qui marquent des
buts mais la personne qui marque le but
elle ne marque pas toute seule il y a
quelqu'un qui lui donne la passe et un
pays c'est aussi ça
passe fort par les bonnes notes vous en
pensez quoi non ça passe par quoi alors
des gens qui réussissent c'est pas
forcément des gens qui sont forts à
l'école parce que c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont forts à l'école que forcément ils
vont réussir ok par exemple
iones on fera à l'école leur métier il
veut pas être grand métier c'est quoi un
grand métier
médecin il y a quoi comme mode grand
métier des grandes études pas forcément
les soignants qui nous ont aidés là
pendant un an et demi
et ouais les infirmiers oui
il y en a qui il y en a qui certes
accédaient à une grande école et avoir
des bonnes notes c'est une réussite mais
il y en a qui il y en a l'école c'est
ils ont des difficultés ou c'est pas
fait pour eux et ils donnent les moyens
de réussir dans d'autres domaines par
exemple le sport ou ou par exemple le
sport qui est très bien payé ou d'autres
choses parce que du coup pour réussir il
faut forcément être bien payé non c'est
être bien payé assez en bonus mais aussi
prendre du plaisir dans ce qu'on fait
exactement ok oui
on a réussi quand on gagne beaucoup
d'argent toi c'est ton point de vue vous
êtes tous d'accord avec ça
on a réussi quand on est fier de nous
une belle phrase vous êtes d'accord
pour moi la réussite c'est qu'on a
réussi à qu'est-ce qu'on voulait faire
comme métier par exemple si on avait un
métier de rêve et on a réussi à le faire
pour moi c'est ça la réussite ok c'est
intéressant vous êtes tous d'accord avec
ça
ok justement est-ce que vous vous avez
l'impression d'avoir réussi
certains de mes rêves le débat c'est
toujours le même est-ce qu'il faut
réussir dans la vie ou réussir sa vie et
c'est en répondant à cette question vous
saurez vous avez envie d'aller mais
évidemment qu'il faut avoir des bonnes
notes évidemment qu'il faut travailler
parce que si tu travailles énormément
tu es pas sûr de réussir mais si tu
travailles pas tu es sûr de pas réussir
si un conseil que sans doute beaucoup de
vos enseignants il faut lire
la base de la réussite c'est la capacité
à lire à lire des romans à lire des
essais à lire des journaux
il faut vraiment parce que ce qui ne va
pas dans le système éducatif on le voit
bien qui est en apparence
normale ça veut rien dire pardonnez-moi
ordinaire c'est que derrière il y a
toute une vision académique des choses
une vision qui est redoutable et qui
fait que ce qui va faire la différence
c'est la culture générale
Othman vous avez juste à l'heure pour
réussir dans sa vie ou alors réussir sa
vie et pour vous est-ce qu'il y a une
différence entre les deux
réussir dans la vie
c'est avoir une fonction ou un salaire
ou quelque chose qui rentre dans ce
qu'on appelle des normes et réussir sa
vie
c'est plus la dimension personnelle elle
est aussi importante et même plus que
l'autre mais les deux on leur importance
est-ce qu'il y a une différence entre
les établissements de banlieue et les
écoles parisiennes est-ce que je
réussirai mieux si j'étais dans un
collège de Paris moi ce que je pense
c'est que dans les deux cas les profs
sont tout aussi bien et qu'ils ont tout
autant la fibre de transmettre et
l'envie transmettre et les élèves font
tout aussi intelligents mais il y a
quand même la question de ce qu'on
appelle l'étudierait certainement plus
tard pendant vos cours de philosophie ou
de Sciences Po le déterminisme social
qui fait que effectivement quand on
grandit dans un milieu social où il y a
un peu moins de lecture où il y a il y a
un vocabulaire qui est peut-être
différent
ça crée des différences de niveau
donc non je ne pense pas qu'un élève qui
a fait toute sa scolarité dans un lycée
de banlieue n'a aucune chance de réussir
par contre ce que je pense et ce que
j'ai vu moi parce que j'étais en collège
en banlieue et ensuite je suis partie en
lycée à Montpellier dans le meilleur
lycée de Montpellier et pour parler très
franchement j'ai galéré vraiment j'ai
passé ma première année de seconde à
travailler dix fois plus que tout le
monde j'étais en internat du coup 10
fois plus que tout le monde pour avoir
un 12 alors que en fait en troisième
j'avais 17-18 de moyenne en banlieue
donc oui on va pas se mentir il y a
quand même une différence mais c'est ni
en termes d'intelligence ni en termes de
volonté de la part des professeurs
pourquoi tu pleures je ne comprends pas
elle a peur de pas être à la hauteur
c'est à dire toi tu n'as pas peur d'être
à la hauteur mais aussi
mais toi tu le montres pas bah oui mais
tu as peur quand même de l'échec bien
sûr qui n'a pas peur de l'échec j'ai
envie de te dire on a tous peur de
l'échec on parlait de des lycées en
banlieue et des lycées des grands lycées
et je voulais savoir si le choix des
choix des lycées est-ce que ils ont des
plus d'influence sur l'avenir que les
notes la réponse est oui c'est à dire
que mais il faut pas être nier cette
réalité
c'est
de ne pas vouloir se rendre compte que à
midi il fait jour c'est une évidence
absolue c'est pas une fatalité de d'être
né Argenteuil bien au contraire c'est
c'est d'être capable de modifier les
règles oui c'est difficile mais tout
autant oui c'est jouable et donc que tu
sois sur un lycée ici ou ailleurs le but
c'est que tu sois le meilleur par
rapport à toi même
et que tu puisses mais faudra un peu de
boulot est-ce que vous avez une des
nouvelles de ces quatre élèves j'ai
d'autres projets avec certains d'entre
eux et
oui on s'écrit régulièrement
ça a pas été facile facile au début
évidemment parce que c'est pas le même
niveau scolaire mais il s'en sort très
bien il est très heureux et s'en sort
très bien il a des bonnes notes il est
passé en classe supérieure c'est génial
et les autres sont du coup dans des
établissements en banlieue mais ça
n'empêche qu'ils ont voilà ils sont
heureux ils ont des bonnes notes et ils
ont toujours des rêves et la vie ne
s'arrêtent pas à un échec et puis c'est
aussi une préparation à la vie d'adulte
dans la vie d'adulte on vit tous des
échecs il faut pas le voir justement
comme un échec Jacqueline
qu'est-ce que l'école méritocratique
c'est une espèce de récompense au mérite
mais c'est quoi le mérite c'est de de
travailler
c'est de trouver forgé vous-même votre
réussite dans cette école c'est
compliqué c'est difficile mais la vie
elle est par elle-même compliquée
difficile mais elle vaut le coup d'être
vécu parce qu'elle vous permet vous
pouvez vous donner les moyens de vivre
vos
dans l'école il y a la boîte à outils
pour tout ça mais il faut les trouver
ces instruments et s'en servir Jeanne tu
avais une dernière question je crois
posée oui après avoir tourné ce film
est-ce que vous pensez vraiment que
l'école était galère
je pense que non
je pense qu'elle l'est pas et je pense
que c'est
elle essaie de l'être en tout cas et
c'est dispositifs sont sont très bien au
final heureusement qu'il y a cette
volonté heureusement qu'il y a des en
fait de créer des dispositifs comme les
cornets mais au final
non elle ne l'est pas et c'est aussi
pour d'autres facteurs on de même de
l'école je pense que pour qu'il y ait
une égalité il faut aussi qu'il y ait
d'autres choses autour de l'école
qui soit mise en place tout ne peut pas
toute la charge de la société ne veut
pas être mise juste entre les murs d'un
établissement scolaire qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait changer vous savez des idées
vous Maéva
le système des notes c'est-à-dire qu'au
lieu de mettre une autre chiffrée ou une
lettre une couleur ou privilégie plutôt
le rendement du travail bien sûr plutôt
ça a été bien et juste mettre quelques
points négatifs mais pas forcément tout
mettre sur une note comme indice ou un
vin pour éviter qu'il y a de la
compétition
oui que les établissements des banlieues
où les établissements des grandes villes
comme Paris ou Lyon bah ils étaient tous
les mêmes niveaux et les mêmes chances
comment on pourrait faire pour que ça se
mette en place
des banlieues tout le monde parte avec
un pays d'égalité
c'est que par exemple
les écoles parisiennes les hautes écoles
bah faudrait que ce soit accessible à
tout le monde et comment on fait du coup
pour les rendre plus accessibles
les établissements et spécialement les
établissements parce que la plupart des
transports iraient les villes et
certains certains monuments par exemple
mais ça relis pas toujours les
établissements
étudiaient dans la banlieue et les
banlieues sur Paris
elle est sec et pas loin d'ici à
Cergy-Pontoise
je pense que c'est pas qu'une question
de de
géographie ou de même s'il faut le faire
évidemment mais je pense votre réussite
avant qui qui modifiera davantage que le
système mais vous avez raison il faut le
corriger on va s'arrêter là
malheureusement l'émission est déjà
terminée merci beaucoup Sonia Didi merci
d'avoir
à Z à la Zone d'Éducation documentaire
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à
toutes ces questions alors une toute
petite précision avant de nous quitter
vous êtes monsieur Abdel Aissou le
président d'un collectif qui s'appelle
mon cartable connecté que vous avez
fondé avec Marc Lavoine et Raymond
Domenech alors on peut découvrir et
soutenir cette magnifique initiative sur
le site Mon cartable connecté.fr et
l'adresse s'inscrit sur vos écrans alors
évidemment merci à vous les élèves merci
beaucoup d'avoir posé toutes ces
questions vous avez été vraiment
pertinent c'était c'était vraiment très
très chouette et puis vous devant votre
écran et bien n'hésitez pas à commenter
l'émission si vous voulez participer
aussi inscrivez-vous ça se passe sur
Twitter hashtag the Dogg mais aussi sur
la page Instagram de la Chaîne
Parlementaire les aides revient très
très vite dans une nouvelle classe avec
un nouveau film vous savez pourquoi et
bien parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour
questionner le monde et ces images allez
salut la classe
[Musique]